NANCY KANWISHER:
OK, so we are now
going to do the third part
in our sort of trilogy
of uniquely human functions.
So starting a few
weeks ago, we moved
from things that are
shared with animals,
like navigation and basic
visual perception-- very similar
between humans and monkeys.
And other number--
all of these things
that are shared with animals,
to talk about functions
that are uniquely human.
And that includes
music and language.
And today, we're going to talk
about the coolest and most
quintessentially
human mental function
and that is thinking about
each other's thoughts.
So to get started thinking
about this, let me remind you
guys of what should
be pretty obvious--
that we human beings
are profoundly
social in many, many
different respects.
So if you think about--
if you recount what
happened in your day
to someone else, pretty much
all of the elements of what
you're recounting our
interactions with other people.
These are the things
we care about.
These are the basic
structure of our lives.
Other people are the source
of our greatest happiness
for most of us.
If you ask people at the end
of life what matters most,
they'll say I
shouldn't have wasted
all that time working so hard.
And my job didn't matter.
And I didn't realize, actually,
it's just other people are
the only thing that matter.
Interactions with other
people, or lack thereof,
are also the source of
one of the deepest kinds
of human suffering
for many of us,
whether it's an everyday thing
like a breakup with a lover,
or a loss of a loved
one, or a family member--
and also depriving people
of social interactions.
This is, like, society's kind
of strongest form of punishment,
is solitary confinement.
Interactions with other people--
our failure to
understand them is
devastating in the
case of autism,
where people struggle
to understand what
other people are all about.
And in terms of our amazing
abilities as human beings,
most of what we know we
learn from other people.
Sometimes, we figure
stuff out on our own.
But if you take an inventory
of all the stuff you know,
you read about it or
somebody told it to you.
You learned it
from other people.
And consequently, some of the
greatest feats of humanity,
from arts to science
to everything else,
are products of people
working together.
OK, further, many people
have hypothesized that social
cognition, or ability to
understand and deal with--
interact with other people--
is one of the strongest
drivers of the evolution
of the human brain.
So many have argued
that the hardest
problem we solve
on a daily basis
is understanding other people.
And it's also a very
important problem.
And so that's a powerful
natural selection force,
understanding other people.
And that has shaped the
structure of the human brain.
Not everybody agrees with
that kind of extreme view,
that it's the primary
driver, but it's
an interesting hypothesis.
And it surely played some role.
Social cognition also is
just a very large percent
of human cognition.
And it's a large in terms
of minutes of every day.
If you tally up different
forms of social cognition,
this is one we're
doing right now--
and we're about to engage in
an hour and 20 minutes of it
right here.
And probably, when
you leave this room,
you'll engage in other
kinds of social cognition.
So it's just a large percent
what we do all day every day,
and it's also a large percent
of what the cortex does.
So roughly that
stuff and other bits
are engaged in different
aspects of social cognition.
OK, so what exactly
is social cognition?
To get a sense of
what is entailed
in social cognition,
which is a very
complex, multi-part,
multifaceted enterprise,
I'm going to show you a
short video of an interaction
between a bunch of 18-month-old
infants and an experimenter.
And what I want you to
do is just watch it.
It's very charming,
but also think
about what these kids
must know to be able to do
what you're about to see.
Can you see the screen there?
OK.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
That little kid in the
corner doesn't know this guy.
He's just been brought
in for the experiment,
and he's just watching this
weirdo doing this thing.
Never met that guy before.
Here's another case.
He's dropped a clothespin.
- Ah!
Oh.
NANCY KANWISHER: What is
the matter with this guy?
[LAUGHTER]
- Oh.
NANCY KANWISHER: Looking
more and more suspicious.
[SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
OK, so what did you notice?
What are those little
kids, 18 months-- oh,
there's another one.
This is cute, but
we don't need it.
Let's go on.
What did you notice about
what those little kids were
able to do?
What is entailed in
being able to do that?
What have they figured out--
lots of things.
Yeah--
AUDIENCE: They
understand intention.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Yeah-- yeah, all they're
doing is watching this guy do
these clumsy actions.
And he's not saying
anything, he's just grunting.
And they're figuring out
what he intends, absolutely.
What else?
Yeah--
AUDIENCE: --sort of being
able to interpret the sounds
of grunts that the
experimenter was making--
so especially, like,
a lot of confusion.
Like, the-- sound.
NANCY KANWISHER: Uh-huh.
Yeah, one could ask
which of those things
are more important-- the
actions or the sounds.
I don't think they
took it apart here,
but it's an
interesting question.
Yeah so they understand some
kind of vocal communication--
not language, but
some kind of intent.
That may be part of it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I meant how
to be helpful without doing--
something for real?
NANCY KANWISHER: I didn't hear.
Without-- sorry.
AUDIENCE: Without
interfering with whatever's
coming in their way.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, they
know how to be helpful.
But not just they know how--
they have a will to be helpful.
Remember, these kids
never met that stranger
before this video started, or
maybe a minute or two before.
So it's fascinating--
not just what
they're able to figure out, but
what they're motivated to do.
Right, that's a
quintessentially human thing,
is to spontaneously help a
stranger who you've never met
before and are not related to.
OK, all right, so--
but focusing more
on the cognitive abilities.
What you need to do to figure
out another agent's actions
is to figure out what
that agent is doing.
And that's externally
observable.
You can watch.
You can use your perceptual
system, construed broadly,
to figure out what
is this person doing
in some general sense.
And that's important, and
subtle, and multifaceted,
but it's nowhere near enough.
Really, what you
want to know is--
why are they doing that thing?
OK, and that's not
directly observable.
You can't see the why
of a person's actions.
You have to infer it.
In fact, to infer it,
you have to infer a bunch
of hidden mental states.
And those things are much
more abstract than just, I'm
picking up the phone.
You know, that's just an action.
You can see it.
But if you try to think about
why am I picking up the phone,
now we're in a whole
different ballpark.
And so what you
need to figure out,
to figure out the agent's
hidden mental states--
you need to figure out what
can that agent see or hear.
OK, and here, it's
really important
to not lose a level here.
We're not talking
about what we can see.
In understanding
another agent, we
need to understand
what that agent can
see about someone else.
OK, so we're getting
kind of meta here--
multiple levels.
OK, we also need to understand
the other agent's desires
and goals of what they want,
or what they're intending, OK.
So how might we figure
these things out?
Sometimes, there are simple
cues that might suffice.
So you might make an
inference like, if a person is
reaching for an object,
they want that object.
OK, so there, the
externally observable thing
might give you a
pretty direct inference
about the internal hidden
state of what the agent wants.
OK, but a lot of times,
that's not going to work.
Right, that's going to work
in some cases, but only a few.
And further, the
percepts and the goals
that we've mentioned
here aren't enough.
OK, they'll work in some
cases, but humans do much more
than that.
So let's consider this case.
Here's an agent who's
doing some action,
and we can observe
their body motions.
And what we want
to understand is
how this other
agent watching them
is going to infer
things about this guy.
OK, so we're
interested in what's
going on in the mind of this
guy, as they watch that guy.
OK, now let's consider
the case that this guy is
trying to understand--
this is Romeo here.
Why did Romeo reach
for the bottle?
OK, well to understand why
Romeo reached for the bottle,
you need to perceive and
infer a whole bunch of things.
You need to see the hand
reaching for the bottle
to know what happened, but
then to really understand
the case of Romeo,
you need to understand
that his intention is to drink
the liquid in the bottle.
That's why he reached for it.
OK, you can't see the
intention to drink the liquid.
You can only see the reaching.
Then, you further
need to understand
why is he intending
to drink the liquid.
Well, because he believes
the liquid is poison.
I don't know why my pop ups are
all messing up here-- whatever.
He believes that Juliet is
dead, and he wants to die.
OK, so all of that
is part of what
is entailed in understanding why
Romeo reached for the bottle.
OK, and crucially the stuff
in red, these things are--
the beliefs and desires are
not directly observable.
They're highly abstract.
And they're crucial.
They are the best way to
explain and predict behavior.
So when we need to
understand other people
and what they're
doing and why, we're
in this abstract space
of beliefs and desires.
We can't see them directly.
We have to observe.
We have to infer
them indirectly.
And they're essential,
because that's
what we need to do to
understand other people.
All right, so we talked before
about perceiving an agent--
I'm sorry, about inferring
what an agent can perceive,
and inferring the agent's
desires and goals.
But as I just
pointed out, we also
need to know the agent's
beliefs-- what they think.
So all of this stuff
in here, inferring
the hidden mental
states of agents
is what we mean by mentalizing,
inferring other people's
mental states.
OK, in the cases we're
talking about here,
we're inferring the
percepts of another agent,
inferring the desires
of another agent,
and inferring the beliefs
of another agent--
OK, all this abstract stuff.
OK, no computer system can
do this, not even close.
See, we can still say that.
We can't say that about
object recognition anymore,
but we have this
little precious reserve
where we can still say that.
No animal can do these things,
except in very restricted
cases.
So there's an active,
ongoing research program
and a bunch of labs testing
chimps in subtle tasks
to try to figure out when
they can infer things
about the mind of another
chimp or a person.
And there are a few
restricted cases
where they can make
some inferences
about the mental
contents of other agents,
but the current dominant view
is that those inferences are
very restricted to very
particular situations,
usually involving
competition over food.
And they don't
generalize in any way.
OK, so in this whole
enterprise, specific cues
like making an
inference that reaching
for x means wanting x
will help in some cases,
but will only get us so far.
OK, we do much more than
that, and the question is how.
All right, so
inferring mental states
to understand other
people involves
inferring their percepts, their
beliefs, and their desires.
OK, so how do we do this?
Well, a first question
that we ask in this class,
and it's kind of a
sensible thing to do,
is we were trying to understand
this whole space of how people
think about another agent's
percepts, beliefs, and desires.
We might just think,
OK, maybe that's just
part of generic cognition.
Who says that's a separate
domain of cognition
that we should study separately?
Maybe we should just
study thinking in general.
Thinking about objects,
thinking about physics,
thinking about people, maybe
it's all the same thing.
OK, so let's start
by considering,
is it really a separate thing
from the rest of cognition?
OK, well, there's a
classic behavioral paradigm
in this field that's provided
some evidence in this.
You may have heard about
this in other classes,
but we'll talk about
it, because it's
so kind of fundamental
to all of the work
on thinking about other
people's thoughts.
And that is called the
false belief paradigm.
It's really a way
of testing beliefs.
And the reason you test
false beliefs rather than
true beliefs is if you ask about
another agent's true beliefs,
then your prediction about
what they're going to do next
is confounded with what
is true in the world.
And if you want to
really tap into what's
going on in their mind,
as opposed to what
would be true in
the world, you have
to use a false belief
to pull those apart.
OK, so the classic
way this is done,
the Sally-Anne task
goes like this.
There are many variants
of it, but this
is the classic,
original version that
appears in hundreds of papers.
So here's Sally and Anne,
and Sally puts her ball
in the basket.
OK, you show this
to little kids--
or animals, too,
versions of it--
we're doing the
little kid version.
You say OK, here's Sally.
She puts her ball in the basket.
I don't know why my pop
ups are screwing up.
Anyway, then Anne comes along.
Sally leaves the
room, Anne comes in,
and moves Sally's ball
from the basket to the box,
and closes the top of the box.
Then the question is,
when Sally comes back,
where will she
look for her ball?
OK, where will she
In the basket, right.
OK, if you do this very simple
question for three-year-olds,
they'll say in the box.
If you do it on five-year-olds,
they'll say in the basket.
OK, adults say in the basket--
you have to think
for a second, right.
If you just kind of blurt
out the first thing that
comes to mind, you'll
behave like a three-year-old
and say in the box.
But if you think for half
a second, you realize, duh,
she doesn't know what
got moved to the box.
She'll look where
she thinks it is--
in the basket.
OK, everybody with
the program here?
OK so that's a very,
very simple task.
It's the basic false
belief paradigm.
And to make it
more vivid, I have
to show you the video
of Rebecca Saxe giving
this task to a bunch of
kids and talking about it.
It's a delightful
video, and I'll
give you a really vivid sense of
how smart a three-year-old is,
and how much they
understand, and yet
how fundamentally and
totally they fail this task--
versions of this task.
Come on, here we go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The first thing
I'm going to show you
is a change between
age three and five,
as kids learn to understand
that somebody else can
have beliefs that are
different from their own.
So I'm going to show you
a five-year-old who's
getting a standard
kind of puzzle
that we call the
false belief task.
This is the first pirate.
His name is Ivan.
Do you know what
Pirates really like?
- What?
- Pirates really like
cheese sandwiches.
- Cheese.
I love cheese.
- Yeah, so Ivan has
this cheese sandwich.
And he says yum,
yum, yum, yum, yum.
I really love cheese sandwiches.
And Ivan puts his
sandwich over here
on top of the pirate chest.
And Ivan says, you know what?
I need a drink with my lunch.
So Ivan goes to get a drink.
And while Ivan is
away, the wind comes
and it blows the sandwich
down onto the grass.
And now, here comes
the other pirate.
This pirate is called Joshua.
And Joshua also really
loves cheese sandwiches,
so Joshua has a cheese sandwich.
And he says, yum,
yum, yum, yum, yum.
I love cheese sandwiches.
And he puts his cheese
sandwich over here,
on top of the pirate chest.
- So that one is his--
- That one's Joshua's.
- And then--
- That's right.
- And this his is on the ground.
- Yeah, that's exactly right.
- So he won't know
which one is his.
NANCY KANWISHER: Spontaneous!
Don't even have to ask!
- Ivan comes back and he says,
I want my cheese sandwich.
So which one do you think
Ivan's going to take.
- I think he's going
to take that one.
- Yeah, you think he's
going to take that one?
All right, let's see.
- I told you.
- Oh yeah, you were right.
You know--
So that's a five-year-old
who clearly understands
that other people can
have false beliefs,
and what the consequences
are for their actions.
Now I'm going to show
you a three-year-old who
got the same puzzle.
And Ivan says, I want
my cheese sandwich.
Which sandwich is
he going to take?
You think he's going
to take that one?
Let's see what happens.
Let's see what he does.
Here comes Ivan, he says,
I want my cheese sandwich.
And he takes this one.
Oh-- why'd he take that one?
- His was on the grass.
- So the three-year-old
does two things differently.
First, he predicts
Ivan will take
the sandwich that's really his.
And second, when he sees Ivan
taking the sandwich where
he left his, where we would say
he's taking that one because he
thinks it's his,
the three-year-old
comes up with
another explanation.
He's not taking
his own sandwich,
because he doesn't want
to, because now it's
dirty on the ground.
So that's why he's taking
the other sandwich.
Now, of course, development
doesn't end at 5.
And we can see the
continuation of this process
of learning to think about
other people's thoughts
by upping the ante and
asking children now
not for an action prediction,
but for a moral judgment.
So first, I'm going to show
you the three-year-old again.
Was Ivan being mean and naughty
for taking Joshua's sandwich?
- Yeah.
- Should Ivan get in trouble
for taking Joshua's sandwich?
- Yeah.
- So it's maybe not surprising--
he thinks it was mean of Ivan
to take Joshua's sandwich,
since he thinks Ivan only took
Joshua's sandwich to avoid
having to eat his own dirty
sandwich.
But now, I'm going to show
you the five-year-old.
Remember, the
five-year-old completely
understood why Ivan
took Joshua's sandwich.
- Was Ivan being
mean and naughty
for taking Joshua's sandwich?
- Yeah.
- And so it's not until age
7 that we get what looks more
like an adult response.
Should Ivan get in trouble
for taking Joshua's sandwich?
- No, because the wind
should get in trouble.
[LAUGHTER]
- The wind should get in trouble
for switching his sandwiches.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER:
OK, so everybody
got the idea of the
false belief tasks--
passed in the four
and five-year-olds,
not in the three-year-old.
And the three-year-old not only
fails to get the answer right,
but when asked why
it happened, he
comes up with a totally
different account.
OK, and you can see that
three-year-old is not a dummy.
Three-year-olds are smart and
can do all kinds of things,
but they don't get
this particular thing.
OK, all right, what
about kids with autism?
Well, kids with autism either
failed this task altogether,
or they pass it much later
than neurotypical kids.
OK, but now we've got
to figure out why.
Why would a relatively high
functioning kid with autism--
say, a 7-year-old
who's got language,
and who seems to
understand the question--
why would they fail this task?
Why would anybody
fail this task?
There's a couple of
things going on here.
The essential element of
the false belief tasks
that we're interested in is that
it requires you to attribute
thoughts to another agent.
Right, that's what this
task was made to tap.
But you might fail it not
just for failing to attribute
thoughts correctly.
You might fail it
for other reasons.
You might fail it because
this task involves
this weird situation where
there's the other agent's
belief, and there's a reality,
and they're different.
And that's kind of confusing.
It's like representing x
and not x at the same time.
Maybe that's just a particularly
generically hard cognitive
thing to do, OK.
And the third possibility
is that the true state
of the world is so
salient and dominant,
it may be hard to just inhibit
that true reality in order
to infer the belief--
a belief is a kind of less
visible, salient thing
than the true
state of the world.
And so maybe just having an
inability to inhibit dominant,
salient representations would
interfere with your ability
to do this task.
So people with autism, or,
in fact, three-year-olds,
might fail for any
of these reasons.
So how are we going to figure
out whether people with autism
are actually failing this task
because of their difficulty
in attributing thoughts?
Well, the way to
figure that out is
to come up with a really,
really clever control task.
This task was invented
by Debbie Zaitchik
when I was in graduate school.
She was my office mate
in graduate school,
and she came up with this task.
And I said, that is
really brilliant.
So we want to figure out
whether it's the belief, per se,
that's the difficulty
in attributing
the thought or the belief
to another agent that's
the crux of the problem.
So in Zaitchik's
false photo task,
the idea is it's a
logically isomorphic task,
but it's about a physical
representation, not
a mental one.
So what you do is you show Sally
putting her ball in the basket.
And then you have what was then,
like, widely known to kids,
a Polaroid photograph--
a camera come along.
We didn't have cell
phones back then,
so it was a Polaroid camera--
takes a picture of Sally
putting her ball in
the basket, and then
Anne moves the ball from
the basket to the box.
And then you ask the kid, where
will Sally look for her ball--
I'm sorry, where is--
sorry, then you
ask the kid, where
is the ball in the photograph?
OK, sorry, I screwed it up.
Here's a belief version.
The kid watches Sally and Anne.
In this case, you do a
photograph version of it,
so there's no--
you're not asking about
another person's beliefs.
You're using a photograph.
And you're showing Sally
put the ball in the basket.
You take a photograph of it,
Anne moves the ball to the box.
And then you ask in the
photograph, where's the ball?
OK, you're not asking
about a mental belief,
you're asking about a
physical representation
in the photograph.
OK, so do you see how--
even though I bungled it
on the first time-- it's really
a logically isomorphic task.
In both cases, you're asking
about a representation that
differs from reality, but
one's a mental representation.
That's where the kids
with autism fail the task.
This is the physical
representation.
Kids with ASD fail the
false belief task, not
the false photo task.
And that rules out
these other accounts,
because in both cases,
there's a representation that
differs from reality.
You have the x and not
x challenge-- right,
that's true of both of these.
And in both cases,
the true state
is kind of more dominant than
the representational state
in the belief, or the photo.
And yet, they have a problem
with the belief version,
not with the photograph
version, suggesting
that this is the correct
account of why they fail.
That make sense?
Was there a question?
Yeah-- OK.
So all of that is
consistent with the idea
that attributing
thoughts to another agent
is a special, distinctive
thing that can be--
that's what I just said.
So we have evidence that
attributing thoughts is
a distinct domain of cognition.
It's just not part of
your generic ability
to think about anything.
And we see that from the fact
that typical children have
this very systematic
developmental time
course, where they
get this at age five,
they don't get it at age three.
And we see it from
the selective loss
of this ability in
kids with autism,
that they get the false belief
task way later than they
get the false photograph task.
Was there a question here?
AUDIENCE: So the kids are never
asked what does Anne perceive.
That question then comes
up in the FP task--
in the false photograph task?
NANCY KANWISHER:
I'm sure people have
done versions of that
task, but tell me
what you're getting at here.
AUDIENCE: I just want to know
whether-- to do an accurate
comparison, I would assume
that the final question remains
the same.
So I would ask the kid, what do
you think Anne perceives given
the change in the stimulus.
And then the kid responds, given
the new material, as to what
the answer--
NANCY KANWISHER: You're trying
to get a tighter control
to the false photo task.
AUDIENCE: Very much, yeah.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
instead of where will she
look for the ball-- yeah.
But it's not really
about what she perceives.
It's about where she
thinks the ball is.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
NANCY KANWISHER: And so
the false belief tasks
have been done every
which way, from where
does Sally think the ball
is, to where will she
look for the ball.
And you get the same
answer in all of those.
So I think that's closer to,
where is it in the-- where
is it in the
photograph is really,
where does she think it is?
That's the parallel.
Yeah, because she's not still
perceiving it at that point.
OK, so that's
behavioral evidence
to suggest that there's
really something
different about inferring
another person's thoughts
and beliefs than there is
from the rest of cognition--
the distinctive
developmental time
course and this kind of
selective deficit in autism.
So what can we learn
from functional MRI?
Is there a special
part of the brain
for making these inferences
about other agents, thoughts,
and beliefs.
OK, so Rebecca and I did
this experiment 100 years ago
where we scanned
people while they
were doing simple verbal tasks.
So we wrote false
belief stories,
and sort of false
photo stories--
generalized-- and
we scanned people
while they lay in the
scanner and just read
these simple descriptions
and answered basic questions.
So you can try this right now.
Here's a false belief story.
You read-- Susie parked her
sports car in the driveway
in the middle of the night.
Nathan moved her
car into the garage
to make room for his minivan.
Susie woke up early
in the morning.
Susie expects to see
in the driveway--
a sports car or a minivan?
Yes.
Sports car, duh.
Right, exactly.
What she thinks is
there, not what is there.
The control experiment that--
we wrote many, many of these--
a volcano erupted on
this Caribbean island
three months ago.
Barren lava rock is
all that remains.
Satellite photos show the island
as it was before the eruption.
In the photos, the island is
covered in rock or vegetation,
right.
OK, so here again, it's just
like Debbie Zaitchik's ASD
control here.
It's-- you're asking about a
representation in the satellite
photo that's no longer
true of reality.
And you have to
distinguish the two.
So we scan people just
doing these tasks.
OK, and if you look in a
whole brain group analysis
that I was much dissing before,
but that's a good first step,
you see-- here's a slice
through the brain like this.
You see a bunch
of hot spots that
respond more when you do
these tasks than those tasks.
OK, and there's a
bunch of these regions.
Deep down in the middle of
the prefrontal cortex here
that you can see in
a slice like that
here is a region called MPFC
for medial prefrontal cortex.
It does all kinds of
interesting things,
and it will get mostly short
shrift in this lecture.
It activates in this task--
for reasons you'll see in a
minute, activates in this task.
Oh god, pop ups have
a mind of their own.
But here's another
region, the right TPJ--
TPJ stands for
temporoparietal junction.
So in me, if my temporal
lobe is going down here,
my parietal lobe is here,
frontal lobe is there.
Temporoparietal junction is
somewhere right around there.
OK-- everybody oriented?
And if we look at that region,
shown symbolically here, what
you see in the time
course of response
in that region doing
this task, is here's
what happens in that region.
This is time here--
many seconds,
as they read and
answer that task.
And here's what happens
when they read and answer
the false photo task-- so false
belief task, false photo task.
That just shows you the
same thing's activation.
You can see it evolve over time.
OK, so what happens
in the MPFC region--
oh god, why is
this not happening.
Is that showing up?
Oh, there it is, OK.
Right-- in the MPFC region,
you see a similar thing.
You get a response
below baseline here.
We'll talk about
that-- what it means
to have a response
below baseline
in some conditions
in the next lecture.
It's actually not
all that mysterious.
It just means that baseline,
remember, is usually
lying in the scanner staring at
a dot-- going dum dee dum dee
dum-- or whatever you
do when you're staring
at a dot in the scanner.
And the key point for
now is just that you also
see a higher response to
the belief than photo case.
OK, so what's going
on in these regions?
This activation,
this higher response,
to the belief than photo case--
even though I was touting what
a brilliant control condition
the false photo task is--
but it's still open to a bunch
of different possibilities.
OK, so those activations
could be just thinking
about a person.
After all, our false belief
stories all involve people,
and our false photo
stories did not.
So maybe this isn't
about beliefs per se,
it's just about thinking
about people in general--
any aspect of people.
OK, or it could be
any mental inference
we make about the internal,
invisible states of a person.
OK-- anything that might
be going on in their head.
Or it might be, particularly,
attributing thoughts
and desires to the person.
OK, so how are we going
to unconfound these--
with a new experiment
and some new conditions.
So here's a new condition
that refers just to a person,
not about their internal
invisible states,
or their thoughts or desires.
Subjects just read
simple stories like--
I see what's happening.
It's not showing--
it's showing something
different on the screen from
what's on my slide here.
I have no idea why.
But anyway, that's why I
keep wondering what's there
and what's not.
OK, so in the external
case, in this condition,
you lie in the scanner
and you read stuff,
like, Andrew just
had a growth spurt,
so he was gangly
and rather awkward.
Like most teenagers, he had bad
skin and bad taste in clothes.
He wore mostly baggy
jeans and flannel shirts.
OK, so it's not riveting,
but it's not boring either.
You read a bunch of these,
they're interesting enough.
OK-- but no mental states
there, just outward appearance.
OK the next condition
refers directly
to the person's thoughts--
Nicky knew that his sister's
flight from San Francisco
was delayed 10 hours.
Only one flight was
delayed so much that night,
so when he got to the airport,
he knew what flight was hers.
OK, not even that
interesting, but it's
talking about what he inferred,
what he knew-- beliefs.
OK, but there's
a third condition
that refers to an
internal state,
but not a thought or a belief.
It refers to a visceral state.
Sheila skipped breakfast because
she was late for the train
to her mother's.
By the time she got off the
train, she was starving.
Her stomach was rumbling and
she could smell food everywhere.
OK, so this case is interesting.
It's vivid.
It refers to a mental
state, but not a thought.
It's a physical state, hunger.
OK, I mean it's a
mental representation
of a bodily sensation.
OK, everybody get
the distinction
between internal thoughts
and feelings, sensations?
OK, so this contrast
is consistent with any
of these hypotheses.
And we're going to test those
hypotheses with these three
conditions.
OK, so here are the
three hypotheses
we just described here, and
here are the three conditions
I just gave.
And I want you guys
to tell me what
we're going to predict that
we will see in the right TPJ
according to each hypothesis--
namely, which of
these conditions
will produce a high
response, and which
will produce a low response.
OK, so let's start
with this case--
on the hypothesis
that the right TPJ
responds whenever you're
reading about a person,
what are we going to find?
Which of these
conditions is going
to produce a high response?
AUDIENCE: All of them?
NANCY KANWISHER: All of
them, yeah, absolutely.
So that's the prediction
here-- all of them.
OK, what about if it's
interested in internal bodily
sensations, or actually, in
any internal mental states?
The last two, absolutely--
both the visceral case
and the thoughts case.
Sorry-- that cell and that cell.
OK, and what about
if it's specifically
about attributing
thoughts to another agent.
Just the last one, right--
OK, very good.
So what do we see?
So first of all, here's
just a localizer task.
Always nice to look at your
localizer and make sure
it worked out.
So this is a response of
the right TPJ to the belief
and photo condition, just
like I showed you before--
higher when you do the belief
task than the photo task.
OK, just a reality check--
key question, what
is the response
of the right TPJ in that main
experiment with the three
conditions we just described?
And here's what it does.
It's high only in the
thought condition,
only when you're reading about,
thinking about another person's
thoughts.
And that's significantly
higher than
either the external properties
or the visceral states.
And those two, even
though it looks
like there's a
little bit of a trend
that visceral is
higher than external,
that's not significant.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: On the
previous slide, is it,
like, thoughts and/or desires?
So like, why can't--
like, I was just confused
about the example
for the visceral case, if
your smelling food everywhere.
Like, couldn't that
fall under it--
NANCY KANWISHER:
That's a good point.
Yes, it could.
Yes, you could infer a desire
in that case, absolutely.
Yeah, that's right.
So yeah, that's a good point.
It's intended to just identify
the vivid, visceral state.
And it's probably hard
to do that with it
without invoking some
kind of desires here.
Yeah, I would consider
it a confound for that,
for that particular example.
I'm guessing it was
not so for the others.
In fact, it sort of
couldn't have been,
given the way this
came out, right?
But good point.
OK, so--
OK, so-- and if you
do a whole group
analysis, the whole
brain, and you
say what bits do you get
in a contrast of reasoning
about another person's
thoughts versus their external
appearance, or their
visceral states,
their bodily sensations?
You get the right TPJ again.
OK, so everybody got this?
This suggests that the right
TPJ is extremely specifically
interested in inferring
another person's thoughts,
not even just their
bodily sensations.
So it's not all mental
states of another person
that engage this region.
I mean, I find this
quite remarkable,
because that's so specific.
Before you hear about
this, you think, OK,
thinking about another person's
thirst or hunger or pain,
is that really different than
thinking about their beliefs?
But oh yes, it's different.
Right?
The TPJ does believe it's not
thirst and hunger and pain.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What about
your own thoughts and--
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, so there's
a whole literature on this.
And I think if you--
OK, so first of all, we need
to get the levels straight.
When you're just
thinking, you're
not thinking about thinking.
You're just thinking,
right, so you're not
engaging this region.
So when we're talking
about thoughts,
we're talking about you
thinking about another person's
thoughts.
So the parallel
would be thinking
about your own thoughts, right.
So I think--
I can't tell you exactly what
the literature is on this,
I'm sure there's
a few experiments.
But I think what
you'd have to do
is adopt that kind
of meta perspective
on yourself, right--
a lot of our thinking
is sort of thinking
about thinking, but not in a
very explicit, separable way.
I'm not being very
clear on this,
but I think if you ask
people for example,
when you saw this surprising
event, whatever it is--
you make something up--
what were you thinking?
You might engage that region.
I realize I'm not totally sure
if there's literature on this.
Heather, is there?
There must be
literature on this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
You get MPFC for that, yeah.
Or go ahead--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: --and very, it's
kind of, like, intricate--
[INAUDIBLE] --it will
two networks that are--
NANCY KANWISHER: But not just
rTPJ, right, rTPJ and other
regions.
Yeah, so you could get
some rTPJ when answering
those kinds of questions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Uh-huh.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, so you
get something in the vicinity.
I'm just trying to get--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Right, but the
other part of this
is, I bet you have to do
something quite explicit
to do that, because
in some sense,
we're thinking about
our own thoughts
kind of implicitly
a lot of the time.
Right, so I'm guessing
that it's when
you ask about it explicitly.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
forget the details of--
[INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OK, anyway, good question.
I'm sorry, I don't have a
totally adequate answer yet.
I'm guessing the
literature doesn't have
a totally adequate answer yet.
OK, all right, so
recall that I mentioned
that the contrast between
doing the false belief
task versus the false photo
task gets not just the rTPJ,
it also gets this
medial frontal region.
OK, and that medial
frontal region
responds more to the belief
than photograph task, like this.
What does it do in this
split between thoughts,
visceral thinking about
other people's thoughts,
their visceral states, and
their external appearance?
It doesn't care.
OK, so there's a real division
between these different brain
regions that are engaged when
you do the false belief task.
The rTPJ is very
specifically interested in--
very specifically
engaged when you
think about another
person's thoughts,
not when you think about
their bodily sensations.
The medial prefrontal region
is engaged in all three
of these conditions.
OK, so what it looks like
is that of these three
hypotheses, any time you
think about another person,
that's true of the MPFC.
Whereas the right TPJ
responds specifically
when you attribute thoughts
and desires to another person.
OK?
OK, now you may have been
wondering about the fact
that all of these
experiments are using words.
It's kind of not, like,
normal social cognition.
You're reading about
all this stuff.
And if these regions
were really doing
what we're claiming
they're doing,
we should be able to find
them in other situations
where you make inferences
about other agents' beliefs.
So in more recent
experiments, they've
been showing Pixar movies
to subjects in the scanner.
So you can just watch
yourself make a few inferences
about the agent's beliefs.
Imagine you're watching
this in the scanner,
and just let's just do a little
bit of it to get the gist.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
No words, it's a key.
OK, so there's a whole little
microcosm of mental states
here.
In other parts of this same
six minute Pixar movie,
there's very vivid
bodily sensations.
There's a porcupine
who inflicts real pain
with porcupine quills,
so there's bodily states,
and inferences
about bodily states,
and inferences about
mental states that go on.
And by showing this movie
to subjects in the scanner,
and then labeling which parts
of the movie require the viewer
to make inferences about
the thoughts and beliefs
of the protagonists, and which
require them to make inferences
about bodily sensations--
like, usually pain--
if you do that contrast,
you find the same set
of regions, the rTPJ and
its left hemisphere bit,
and you find some
medial prefrontal stuff,
and you find some other stuff.
OK, so what does that mean?
That means that you don't need
words to identify this region.
If you induce the same
cognitive processes just
from watching a
wordless movie, you
show the same
selective activations.
And that's cool,
because it tells us
that this is not about some
kind of verbal reasoning.
It's really about the kind
of deeper cognitive process,
whether you do it
based on a movie,
or based on a
bunch of sentences.
And that's a powerful
generalization.
We like imaging results,
where the result generalizes
across very different
kinds of tasks.
And this really
strengthens the evidence
that this is really what's
going on in this region.
And it also means you can
look for this region in kids.
OK, and I didn't manage to
fit that into this lecture,
but there's a whole
other research enterprise
where, in Rebecca's lab,
they've been scanning kids
watching this Pixar
movie, and asking
how that region develops.
And they find that, actually,
the region continues
to develop even after age four.
It continues to develop.
And what happens is it
doesn't so much get bigger
as it gets more selective.
In the younger kids you
get activation, both for--
well, it's just less selective.
Anyway, so this
shows generalization.
So now we've shown
that we see the rTPJ is
selective for thinking about
other people's thoughts.
We see that with false photo--
false belief versus
false photo contrast.
We see that it's
highly specific.
It's not just any thoughts
you have about another person.
And we see it generalizes
to Pixar movies.
OK, so let's consider now
moral reasoning as a test
case for theory of mind.
Why moral reasoning?
Well, if you think
about it, reasoning
about what's a morally
acceptable or unacceptable
action on the part of another
person is all about what
the person intended
and what they knew.
OK, so intent is
very fundamental.
It's built into
the legal system.
Think about the
difference between murder
and manslaughter.
Right, they both involve
killing another person,
but one is with intent, and
the other is accidental.
And our common moral
reasoning and our legal system
cares deeply about
that difference.
So for example, I'm going to
give you a moral reasoning
task, and just think about this.
And your task is going to be to
decide how morally permissible
is the action described here--
Grace's action in particular.
OK, so Grace and her
friend are taking
a tour of a chemical plant.
And when Grace goes over
to the coffee machine
to pour some coffee,
Grace's friend
asks for some sugar in hers.
And there's white powder in
a container by the coffee.
The plot thickens.
The white powder is a very
toxic substance left behind
by a scientist, and
therefore, it's deadly
when ingested in any form--
versus-- but the container
is labeled sugar,
so Grace believes that the
white powder by the coffee
is sugar left by
the kitchen staff.
So grace puts the substance
in her friend's coffee,
and her friend drinks
the coffee and dies.
Now, your question is
how morally permissible
was Grace's action,
on a scale from one,
to totally not OK, morally
forbidden, to seven, morally
permissible.
OK, so think about
that on a scale,
and write down your number
on a piece of paper.
You don't have to divulge it.
OK, everybody got the question?
Everybody decided, more or less?
OK, write down your number.
Now, consider a slightly
different case--
slightly, but crucially
this case is known as
the accidental harm case.
Now consider the
case where instead--
OK, instead of being labeled
sugar, you get the same story,
but now the container
is labeled toxic.
So Grace believes that the white
powder is a toxic substance
left behind by a scientist.
Nonetheless, she
puts the substance
in her friend's coffee and
their friend drinks a coffee
and dies.
Now, consider how
morally permissible
is Grace's action, from one,
to totally not OK, to seven,
morally permissible.
And write down your number.
OK, how many people gave
a lower number-- that is,
more morally forbidden for the
second one than the first one.
OK, if you didn't, you probably
weren't paying attention.
OK, so you can see
that it's the crux
of the matter what
Grace believed
when she did the action.
OK, that's why we're talking
about moral reasoning
here as a test case
of theory of mind,
because what the agent knew
at the time of the action
is of the essence in thinking
about the moral status
of their action.
OK, everybody got that--
OK, so this is a
powerful test case.
And notice that-- also in
the clip that I showed you
from Rebecca's Ted
Talk, she showed
that kids' ability to use an
agent's knowledge in doing what
you guys just did, that
kicks in a little bit later
than the standard
false belief task.
So sometime after they get the
basic idea of false belief,
they start to apply.
It takes a while to kick
in in this other case.
OK, so this is known as
intentional harm as opposed
to accidental harm.
OK-- it's just the
terminology in the field.
OK, so what do you think
will happen in autism?
If we ask people with
autism these two questions--
and what do you think
will happen if we
apply TMS to the right TPJ?
It's right out there on
the lateral surface, just
asking for it.
So it's a totally
doable experiment.
It's been done, what
do you think happens?
OK, let's take the
case with autism.
How do you think
people with autism
will respond to
these two questions?
The same as you guys did?
Yeah-- yes, Shardoul.
AUDIENCE: Probably the
average distance between--
the average distance between how
bad they think the second one
would be less than
the first one--
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes, exactly.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because
they might not be
able to make the
distinction between Grace
knowing that the
container was toxic
versus the container
being labeled toxic.
Like, both then, would
be confounded with just
like truth and consequence.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Absolutely, absolutely.
Did everybody get that--
share that intuition?
To the extent that autism
is a particular deficit
in understanding what another
person knows or believes,
that's the only difference
between these two cases.
To the extent that you have
difficulty representing that,
you will have less
of a difference
in your moral judgment
about these two things,
because you have a hard time
representing that person's
knowledge.
It's not that autism is a
deficit in moral reasoning.
It's that moral
reasoning entails
thinking about other-- at least
these cases, not all of them--
but these cases involve thinking
about other people's thoughts
and taking them into account.
And to the extent that
that's difficult for you,
you will make less of a
distinction, exactly--
right.
Yeah, was there a
question back there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, OK.
OK, what do you
think will happen
if you zap the rTPJ
with TMS while subjects
are doing these tasks?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They'd be, like--
[INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, yeah.
That's the prediction.
If the rTPJ is the main bit
that's doing the inference
about-- it's representing
the beliefs of others,
then if you zap it, you
might change people's moral
inferences--
moral judgments.
That's pretty wild.
That's what happens.
Zap the rTPJ, and they
make a smaller distinction
between accidental harm
and intentional harm.
OK, so both of those
things are true.
I won't drag you through all
the details of the experiments.
But the basic findings from
this whole line of work
show that, first of
all, neurotypical people
agree, as you guys did, that
accidental harm is more morally
permissible than
intentional harm.
OK, and people with
autism give less
forgiveness for accidental harm
compared to intentional harm
than neurotypicals.
OK-- just because that ability
to represent the key knowledge
that tells you
it's accidental is
something they're not good at.
What is the role of the rTPJ?
The data show that forgiveness
for accidental harms--
first of all, I left
this out before,
is correlated in
neurotypicals with activation
of the right TPJ
during moral judgment.
So if you just measure
across a whole bunch
of those moral judgment
problems how strongly activated
was your rTPJ as you
read that problem, that's
correlated with your
ability to forgive somebody
for accidentally
harming someone,
again showing that there's
a relationship between your
representing the thoughts
and beliefs of another person
and your using that information
to exonerate them from harm
they didn't intend.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For someone with
autism syndrome, are they--
is it different for thoughts
versus external actions
of the things?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, so first of all,
I'm treating autism
very superficially here.
It's an extremely
heterogeneous thing
that varies not just along
a spectrum, you know,
which it clearly does, but
probably along many spectra,
and is highly heterogeneous.
So these experiments are just
done in high functioning adults
who are--
totally pass false
belief tasks--
they pass them later in life,
but they get to-- otherwise,
you can't test them on
these kinds of experiments.
And the effects
are quite subtle.
They're just a slightly
lesser difference
between accidental
and intentional harm.
OK, so just to clarify that,
which I probably should have
said.
But your question
is, are the deficits
in autism specific to
thinking about thoughts
rather than thinking
about actions?
This is ongoing work,
but a lot of research
has shown that it is more
specific to thoughts,
and that a lot of the
stuff you read about just
basic perceptual difficulties--
I mean, most studies find
that people with autism
are a little bit worse
at face recognition,
but not much worse.
In tasks asking about
goals of actions,
like reaching for objects--
what is that person's intention?
Mostly, they don't find
a deficit in autism.
So the perceptual--
basic seeing people
and seeing what they're
doing is much less impaired.
That's what the current
literature suggests.
There's always the
worry that we're not
asking in the right way, or
testing in the right way.
And the literature is highly
inconsistent from one study
to the next.
I used to work on autism and I
just couldn't stand it anymore,
because every time
a study's done,
it gets the opposite
of the previous study.
I think as a population--
so heterogeneous.
But from a gloss, it
looks like there's
more of a deficit in the
inferences about thoughts
than inferences about actions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I just
want to clarify.
So the autistic subjects
are also explicitly told
that Grace believes--
blah, blah, blah.
Yes?
It's explicit--
NANCY KANWISHER: No, it's
exactly what I gave here.
Yeah, no Grace believes--
yeah, you're right.
Grace believes.
Yes--
AUDIENCE: Explicitly being--
and in spite of that, it's--
[INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yep, yeah, yeah.
And so I think you can think
of this as a subtle case.
These are people who pass the
explicit false belief task.
But like the 7-year-old
kids, there's
one thing if you're asked--
what does this person believe,
and another if you're
asked a moral reasoning
task for which you have
to realize to bring
the belief into account.
It takes more of your
own kind of active--
was there another question?
AUDIENCE: What if you ask--
like, instead of Grace,
what if you say it's you?
NANCY KANWISHER: What if what?
AUDIENCE: You ask
them about themselves.
So you and your
friends are taking
a tour of the chemical
plants, and give them
the exact same scenario.
Would that be any different?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
that's interesting.
It's like the question
about to what--
sorry--
AUDIENCE: What was the question?
NANCY KANWISHER: Question
is, suppose you ask people
with autism this same question,
but it's not about Grace.
It's about you.
You do all of this.
I'm not sure.
Good question.
Probably, somebody
has looked at that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure if
you answered already, but do
people with autism
have something
different in their rTPJ?
NANCY KANWISHER:
We're getting there.
You should absolutely
be wondering that,
and I haven't yet.
And we're getting there.
Good that you ask.
In fact, that's probably
my very next slide.
OK, so causal role--
we showed the causal role of the
rTPJ in neurotypical subjects,
you zap the rTPJ and you
slightly reduce the difference
in moral permissibility
of the accidental harms
and the intentional harms.
OK, so all of these
findings suggest
that the rTPJ is
causally engaged
in understanding the difference
between intentional and
accidental actions, and
that ability is specifically
disrupted and autism, All.
Of which leads to the
natural prediction
that Gisella just made
about the rTPJ in autism.
So what do you think?
Is the rTPJ affected in autism?
How many-- raise
your hand if you
think there's going
to be something
different in the rTPJ autism
versus typical subjects.
OK, raise your hand if
you think there isn't.
Not sure-- OK, well,
you're sort of both right
in different ways.
OK, so the answer is this--
so in Rebecca Saxe's lab,
they did a study with
a really large number
of typical subjects.
It's-- because of this
heterogeneity in the autism
population, it's really hard
to get a stable result you can
believe.
And it helps to have
a really large--
it's hard to get
enough autism subjects,
so we try and we get
as many as we can.
And the most you ever get
in a study around here
is 20, 30, and that's
a big struggle.
But it helps to have a really
large neurotypical control
population to reduce
your error bars
on what the neurotypical
population shows.
So this study is probably
the biggest that's been done.
They had 31 high functioning
people with autism and 462
neurotypical individuals.
They didn't just go run
400 new subjects for this.
When you run that
localizer task,
you've got it in
every study you run.
And so then you can take all
those localizer tasks across
hundreds of subjects-- so--
and so what they find is,
both if you look at regions
of interest analysis,
like find rTPJ,
and if you do a whole
brain group analysis,
you find no differences
between people with autism--
high functioning
people with autism--
and typical subjects in the
size, location, or response
magnitude of the rTPJ.
OK-- when people do
theory of mind tasks.
So you should be surprised.
Everyone is surprised.
You all made the prediction.
Everyone else made
the prediction too.
And that's pretty bizarre.
But does that mean that the
rTPJ is not affected in ASD?
Shardoul?
AUDIENCE: If we feed it-- the
information from the rTPJ is
not used by other
parts of the brain to--
[INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: That's
a great hypothesis.
Maybe the information
is in there,
and it's some kind of
a disconnection thing,
and so it can't be accessed
by other processes.
Right, absolutely.
What's another hypothesis?
Yeah, Isabelle?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: It's being processed
in a different order?
NANCY KANWISHER: In
a different order.
What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, but then we'd
have to think about how the
different temporal order would
lead to the different
behavioral outcomes.
Right, it might.
Yeah, David.
AUDIENCE: Maybe it's given a
different priority, so, like,
while you're processing
there, I'm not being--
[INAUDIBLE] --the person
itself [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
OK, so it might be there,
but less salient
or less important.
But how is that going to account
for the lack of a difference
between the ASDs and typicals.
Remember, you run your basic
false belief versus false photo
contrast, and you find the rTPJ.
And surprisingly, even in
this fairly large sample,
it looks the same in size,
location, and response
magnitude in the ASDs
and in the typicals.
Now, I left something out.
This is high functioning
adult ASDs who can now
pass the false belief task.
Right, that's crucial,
because that's
the task you're
doing in the scanner.
If they don't
understand the task,
there's no point scanning
them kind of going, huh, what?
Right, so these are people
who are very high functioning.
And they can totally
do the task--
right, otherwise you
can't run the experiment.
So-- yes?
AUDIENCE: What are the major
differences that you're finding
then, if it informs [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Well,
that's a very good question.
That's another reason that
I stopped working on autism.
[LAUGHTER]
There's a whole
battery that you run
to try to establish that these
people, officially, really,
for the purposes of scientific
study, count as having autism.
And these people,
really, officially don't.
At MIT, you need to run
those studies on everyone,
because some of your
control subjects
end up in the other group.
And so those are a whole
kind of battery of things,
from involving an hour long
interview with a trained
person who tallies things like
how much eye contact is made,
and what kind of give and
take happens in conversation,
and all that kind of stuff.
AUDIENCE: I just don't--
I guess for the
experimenters, I mean--
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --team.
Their behavioral response
might not necessarily
be the rTPJ, but
some other factor.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, absolutely.
So yes, it's possible that
the rTPJ is absolutely
fine in people with
autism, and there's
no difference, as those initial
results seem to suggest,
and that whatever differences
you see with autism reside
elsewhere.
But that's surprising,
given all the stuff
I've said over the last
hour about how, at least,
in the case of moral reasoning,
these same high functioning--
the same people who show the
same activation of the rTPJ
have slightly different
moral reasoning, right.
So there's-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: My point isn't that.
It's-- or so, for moral
reasoning, for example,
could be--
what they base
their morals off of
might not be determined
by some other path--
I don't know.
They might have a slightly
different idea of what morals--
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yep, that's true.
Yep-- Nava?
AUDIENCE: This test, they
functioned the same way--
the people who are
being examined?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --in the same way.
But in a different test,
they performed different.
So why don't they test
them when performing those?
NANCY KANWISHER: Good, good--
exactly.
So we're in this
funny position of--
we've sort of identified
theory of mind inferences
as a critical
difficulty in autism.
But these are people--
the only ones we can
scan on that kind of task
are people who are going
to already pass it.
So we're already in
a weird situation.
Now, you might have predicted
that they could pass it
based on other cognitive
abilities-- right,
that they come up
with another strategy.
And in that case, they
wouldn't be using their rTPJ,
but another hypothesis is
it just develops later.
They've got it.
There it is.
They use it.
It activates the same.
That's yeah-- and so your point
is, why don't they test them
on the moral reasoning task?
Right, and see if
it comes online?
Right?
AUDIENCE: Well, the one
that they can't function on,
because--
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: --they don't
even know when to use it?
NANCY KANWISHER: That's right.
That's right.
It's a very good suggestion.
That's probably been done.
And I don't know this.
Heather, do you know
if people scanned ASDs
doing the moral reasoning task?
Probably Leanne,
has done that right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I don't know.
NANCY KANWISHER: It's a
really good suggestion,
and I actually now
can't think why
they wouldn't have done that.
Do you mind just going
on PubMed and look--
it would be Leanne Young.
And it would be--
yeah, moral reasoning and fMRI.
I bet she's done that.
Maybe Heather will get
you this, because it's
a very good suggestion.
Yeah, why not test them on
the thing that's different.
OK, anyway, what I'm getting at
here is-- all these hypotheses,
you guys are raising
are very good ones.
But there's another
one, which is, maybe
the rTPJ isn't functioning right
even though we see it activated
more when they do
the false belief
task than the false photo task.
Maybe we'd see a
difference if we
looked at the pattern of
responses in there, right?
All right, so in this
study, Koster-Hale and Saxe
did something that should be
very familiar to you guys.
They took these two
cases, sort of a version
of what you're suggesting--
yeah, maybe it does entail it.
I think of it as
an MVPA experiment,
but actually, Heather,
that's the thing to look at--
does Koster-Hale
see a difference
in overall magnitude?
And that I don't know.
Anyway, they did
the MVPA version,
so you have subjects
do those same tasks--
the accidental harm,
the intentional harm.
You split your data in half.
And you ask whether
the rTPJ represents
the difference between
accidental harm
and intentional harm.
OK, everybody get why this
is a sensible thing to do?
OK, so first you do that in
neurotypical subjects, OK?
And you find-- here is the--
remember, this is
the original Haxby
version, the correlation within
versus correlation between.
So this is a correlation
within, and that's
a correlation between.
So this is accidental--
the pattern
in the rTPJ for accidental
harm, to accidental harm
across stories, and
intentional to intentional
is higher than from accidental
to intentional here.
I'm sort of skipping
over the details,
hoping you guys remember this.
Is this making sense?
OK, so typical classification
with correlations,
and you see that that was
significant in this group
of subjects, of
typical subjects.
OK, so that's cool--
so there's information
in the rTPJ about
whether an action was
intentional or accidental.
That's cool.
Now we've learned
something more than just
it activates when
you do these tasks.
We know something about
what it represents.
But you might say,
oof, that's so teeny.
Ick-- yeah, it was
significant, but really?
So what do you do in that case.
AUDIENCE: Do it again?
NANCY KANWISHER: Do it again.
Absolutely.
You don't go find some fancier
stat that gets your p level,
so you have to
start-- no, no, no.
You do it again.
Rebecca and her lab members,
being good scientists,
did it again.
And they got the same thing.
Excellent-- new
bunch of subjects,
new bunch of stories, replicate
and generalize, do it again.
And so yes, indeed, we can--
the spatial pattern
contains information.
Further, you can then--
again, in this bunch of
neurotypical subjects--
look at the degree
to which subjects
rated the moral
permissibility to be
different in the
intentional and accidental.
Look at their behavioral
ratings during the task.
That's here.
And you can see,
that's correlated
with the degree of pattern
information in the rTPJ.
OK, everybody get that?
So the more you pay attention
to that distinction,
behaviorally, when
you're doing the task,
the more you think accidental
harm is really much more
OK than intentional harm.
The greater that difference
in your behavioral ratings,
the greater the discrimination
ability in your rTPJ
while you're doing it.
OK, so that's a further link
that's where the action is--
just a correlation,
not causation.
But it's a nice one.
Yeah, OK-- so all of this is.
Yeah?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's the [INAUDIBLE]
there's no [INAUDIBLE]
and there is a [INAUDIBLE]
--so neurotypicals have
a difference in [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Just
univariate overall magnitude,
accidental versus intentional,
in neurotypicals, but not
in ASDs.
Aha, so it's not just
a pattern result.
AUDIENCE: Interaction--
it's in the text.
It's not in--
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, OK, OK.
OK, but that's the--
AUDIENCE: --interaction
of, not a--
it's just--
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
but then the version
of Nava's question, which
I resonate to very much,
is if you just did the original
kind of Dufour thing of--
is the rTPJ just as
big and selective,
and is it in the same place?
Just--
AUDIENCE: If you did the
Dufour thing, though,
it [INAUDIBLE] there's a huge
[INAUDIBLE] so you're unable
to--
NANCY KANWISHER: That's true.
OK, so they don't have the data.
OK.
AUDIENCE: There's no way.
You have to have the--
OK, fair enough.
OK, good point.
OK, so that's why--
you asked that question,
it's a very good question.
I'm thinking, yes, they
should have done that.
Reason they didn't do it is--
they could have the
big sample because they
were using localizer data,
which they had from study
after study after study.
Every time you run a
theory of mind test,
you run that localizer.
And so then you just
go back a few years,
and you've got 300
subjects, right.
But they didn't run the
moral reasoning task
on hundreds of subjects, and
so they don't have the power
to be able to see it.
Yeah-- OK, fair enough.
OK, so back to this.
This is just showing that in
the neurotypical subjects,
there's pattern information
in the rTPJ about intentional
versus accidental harm.
Everybody got that--
and it's correlated
with your behavioral reading
of the moral permissibility.
OK, so that's cool.
So does rTPJ distinguish between
accidental and intentional harm
in ASDs?
OK, so these are the
data I just showed you.
Actually, they did three
experiments showing this here--
into neurotypicals.
And here's the ASD data--
no difference at all.
OK, so what that means is even
though ASDs have the same size
and location and
magnitude of response
of the rTPJ in the
standard localizer
task as typical subjects,
the key difference
that's been found so far is
that in neurotypical subjects,
the rTPJ holds information
about the distinction
between intentional
and accidental harm.
And in ASDs, it doesn't.
OK, that's probably just
one of a bunch of things
that are going to be different.
This is, as far as I know, the
only one that's been published.
I see some squints.
Are you not getting this, or do
you have a question about it?
AUDIENCE: What happens
to the other deficit
in the behavior, sort of
being called [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Also, I have to
ask, is this exactly the same?
NANCY KANWISHER: The false--
there isn't an obvious
discrimination that you can do.
See, the nice thing about the
moral reasoning task is it's
got these two outcomes-- these
two conditions, accidental harm
and intentional harm.
So that gives us a way to go
in and do the pattern analysis
questionnaire.
So with false
beliefs, you'd have
to think of some other
dimension to look at.
And the experiments
are not set up
that way with stimuli that are
on either side of a dichotomy,
so that you can do
the discrimination.
You could do representational
similarity analysis,
actually, come to think of it.
Then, you wouldn't have to
have the whole dichotomy.
That's interesting.
OK, Heather, has
Rebecca done that?
You're my informant here.
You could take--
OK, so Shash is
suggesting, why not
ask this kind of question
of this standard localizer
experiment?
And I said, well, it wasn't set
up with an obvious dichotomy.
And then I was
thinking, actually, you
could take all of the
belief conditions,
and you could do an RSA
on those in the ASDs
and on the typicals, and ask if
their patterns are different.
Right?
I bet they've done that.
See what I mean?
Anyway, all right, I'll stop
speculating and just ask.
She's right there,
two floors up.
I can just ask.
All right-- anyway,
does everybody
get this basic idea here?
So the thing-- the rTPJ is
there in the high functioning
people with autism,
but it doesn't
hold the same information.
OK-- all right.
All right, so where do
we get with all of this?
We used all of this
stuff on moral reasoning
as a way to look at the
rTPJ and theory of mind.
We found that people
with ASD put less weight
on a person's
beliefs when judging
the moral permissibility
of an action.
TMS to the rTPJ
disrupts moral judgment.
Pattern analysis shows
that the TPJ distinguishes
between intentional
and accidental harm
in neurotypicals, but
not in people with ASD.
OK, so there's a nice little
story developing here.
I'm sure it's not
the whole deal.